thank you for
having me here this has given me an
opportunity
to sort of look back on some of the
problems i used to work on a while ago
sort of reminded of this story of this
man who
who says i talked to my father 10 years
ago
i was surprised how dumb he was and i
talked to him yesterday and i was
surprised how much he had learned in the
last 10 years
i feel like an old man uh looking back
on this area of data streams
um so
just to locate people i'm sure heard
this little puzzle before let me start
with the by now classical puzzle
you have two players a and b and uh the
numbers one through n
and uh what a does is show the numbers
one through n in some permuted order
to b but leaves out one of the numbers
it shows everything
shows n minus one numbers leaving out
one of the numbers
and b's task is to find what was the
number that was left out
by a okay obviously if
b had a memory to sort of keep track of
all the numbers
that uh he's seen it'll be easy for him
to figure out what was the number that
was left out
uh but we're going to assume that b has
a very small amount of memory okay can
just remember a couple of numbers
perhaps but not all the numbers
and um
by now this is available on puzzle and
the question is how does b find the
missing number
and there's a very simple solution
um
excuse me one yeah but this very simple
solution says that
uh b does not keep track of each of the
numbers that is shown b just keeps track
of the sum of the numbers that's been
shown
and since every number is shown only
once you know that the total sum of n
numbers is n times
n plus 1 over 2. and so if it keeps the
running sum
then if you subtract it out at the end
of n minus one number she wouldn't know
what the
missing number was and that would be
exact okay so very simple puzzle to show
you that
with even with even if it's small number
of bits
sometimes you can solve the problem
exactly in this case find the missing
number exactly okay
if you're really interested in thinking
about this puzzle more you can you may
want to generalize it and see what
happens if
if a leaves out two of the numbers
rather than one missing number
or more generally what happens if a
leaves out
k numbers okay then the algorithms
become more interesting
i want to give you another a different
puzzle
which is taking trying to take the same
concept by trying to push it a little
bit further okay what if we had
only one memory item or one word memory
okay
so imagine that a now alice sees a bunch
of items
one after another and at every moment
alice or a has to maintain the median of
the item seen so far
okay and again if
address could keep all the items seen so
far then they can sort the items or find
the median of items at every moment and
return the correct answer
but here we are going to assume that
alice can only maintain
one word of memory it can maybe just
remember one number
and nothing more than that and the
question is can you still solve this
problem of finding the median
if you think about it median is a very
complicated aggregate
and it's not as simple as average
so you know so median is a complicated
aggregate you'll soon be able to prove
that in the worst case you cannot really
exactly keep track of the median
and so you may want to sort of weaken
the problem in order to make some
progress so one way to weaken the
problem
is to say that each of the numbers that
alice sees
is generated independently randomly from
some distribution
okay and what and what alice does not
know is a distribution
and again these are numbers from some
range and they're being uniformly
randomly generated
and you want to know if addis can
maintain one memory location and be able
to estimate the median
okay we'll turn out that alice cannot
exactly enter the
estimate cannot calculate the median
correctly
but there's a very simple and cute
algorithm for figuring out
and estimate some sort of some
approximation to median okay
what i like about this puzzle is that
when you hear the puzzle you think about
what values do in just one memory
location also able to
remember only one item okay if you think
about it there's not much
artists can do and the most natural
thing for alice to do is to say at every
moment there's one number which is the
guest median and when you see the new
number
more than
your current number then you increment
your current estimate by one
and if it's less than your current
number you decrement your current
estimate by one
so obviously there are issues like d1
increment by one or some constant or
some
more intelligently and so on but roughly
the idea is that once you drift it to
somewhere
in the close enough to the median then
with constant probability anytime you
move away from that region of around the
median you'll always get pulled back to
the
region close enough to the median okay
so
you know we have some sort of estimate
of the median by just simply remembering
nothing about the past but just tracking
the current
median our estimate and what the the new
a new number that arrives in front of
alice
so you can try to generalize this method
for what would you do if you want to
keep track of not the median but maybe
quantiles and so on
okay and what i again like about this
puzzle is that
it's a very simple natural algorithm
you're going to do a little bit of hard
work if you want to
actually analyze it and it tells you
that but
some things are possible even with very
limited amount of memory okay maybe not
exact answers certain amount of
approximations
okay these are not typically
approximations for this particular
problem you won't get approximation that
is
in the spirit of what we prove in
theoretical computer science uh but i'm
happy with it i think it's
you know i don't know if i'll rock this
year but now i've been spending a lot of
time with economist so my theorems are
not quite the same spirit as the
theoretical computer science theorems
so i want to start from here this
intuition that
there are problems that you can solve
with a very small amount of memory
and i want to give two basic primitives
that in the last 10 15 years this area
has developed and these are
nice primitives that once you know them
you can apply them in a bunch of
different ways to solve many problems
okay and i want to talk about sort of
newer topics in this area
uh the first primitive i want to talk
about is called the countermean sketch
and it it tries to solve the following
problem okay
what you have is a very large array okay
of items one through n
uh a and sized array and what you see
are updates to the array okay so you see
either increment some position or a
decrement some position and you see a
whole bunch of
these are these updates and these
updates are the property that you never
decrement the counter below zero so
they're always non-negative these
counters
and you want to keep track of these
updates and at every moment you might be
asked what is the ith position of this
array okay so it's an indexing problem
in databases we know that this is a
key primitive for a lot of database
accesses okay
and we also know how to solve the
problem more or less from our you know
undergraduate algorithms classes that
you can either declare a hash array or
you can do a
sort of balanced tree b trees and so on
and solve this problem
but all of those methods assume that you
can store the entire array okay once you
can store the entire array
for each item you can increment in
decrement and you can look up any item
very quickly
okay and in the spirit of streaming
we're going to assume that
uh we don't have the space to store the
entire array
we're going to work with the sublinear
space or in fact logarithms make our
poly logarithmic space
and
this particular problem has a very
simple solution
what you do is you don't keep the entire
array but you're going to use some hash
functions
and you're going to take the array of
the domain of size n
and map it to a small number of counters
using a hash function and you're going
to do this a few times using a few hash
functions
okay and all our algorithms guarantees
are going to have some approximation
epsilon
a term epsilon and they're also going to
be probabilistically right
so there's going to be some probability
of success or failure of delta okay
and these two parameters are going to
tell us how many hash functions we use
and how wide is each hash function
okay so in particular what you do in the
first is that when you see an item i
you hash it to a bucket and the number
of buckets would be
something like one over epsilon it'll be
proportional it'll be dependent on the
epsilon approximation
and wherever it falls on back i do
increment the counter
or decrement the counter depending on
whatever the update was to the eighth
location okay
so and use a different hash function for
different rows so each eye will
update one of the buckets in each of the
rows okay
and number of hash functions is going to
be log 1 over delta where delta is going
to be
going to determine the probability of
success okay so in other words
all we have is a two-dimensional array
of counters
which we increment our decrements for
each update we go to one count on each
row
given by the hash function and we
perform the operation of incremental
decrement of that counter
and then when
oh all right and then when there's a
query that what is fi
we know we can take i and hash in
through each of each of the hash
functions and go to each bucket
the bucket will hash into each of the
rows and whatever is the counter there
we return the minimum value of those
counters okay and that's our estimation
procedure
so it's a simple algorithm and what we
can show about this data structure
is that when there's a query for i
the estimate that we return will be at
least always the correct answer
and that's one-sided guarantee then with
probability at least one minus delta
it's going to be
at most the correct value of i plus
something that depends on some of all
the other
items so
we're using a amount of memory that is
proportional to 1 over epsilon and 1
over and log 1 over delta
there's no n in this amount of space
that we use so
it's a very small data structure for any
large n
therefore we don't expect to get an
accurate we don't expect to get the
exact answer we're going to get some
approximations and
this claim tells you that the estimated
return will be always the correct answer
but it's at most the correct answer plus
epsilon times the sum of all the other
values in the array it's a very simple
uh proof to realize this um
if you look at the look at any
particular row and look at the
item we landed on some bucket and look
at what's the contribution of all the
other items
to this bucket well it's the sum of all
the other items
divided by the number of number of
buckets
and number of buckets is one over
epsilon so this will be epsilon times
the sum of all the items
there's a constant e there only for
making sure that the calculations are
precise
so the total volume divided by number of
buckets would be the contribution
of other items to the bucket where the
item landed
and so now you want to ask what's the
probability that the estimate
is larger than the quantity that we
claimed well it's the contribution of
the
item plus the contribution of the other
items so probably that that exceeds this
quantity would be some constant time
suspected
value the expected value we already have
is one over
number of buckets times the total volume
so if you do a little bit of calculation
you realize
that in each of for each hash function
you're going to have some sort of
constant probability
you're going to have
one over e kind of probability of
this estimate exceeding this upper bound
we have and then since we return the
minimum value
then we know that the only way we could
be wrong in the estimate is if each one
of the estimates
estimates from each one of the hash
functions turned out to be above the
estimate about the correct
about the claim and therefore you can
sort of multiply all the probabilities
and you have
log one over delta exponent term coming
in so you have overall probability of
delta
so this is a very simple argument that
you see a lot in theoretical computer
science
uh an easier way to understand it is
think about just what happens in a
single hash function
and then assume that we have sufficient
number of hash functions that you can
drive down the probability
of error the way you want it and then a
single hash function
you're going to be wrong because the
contribution of other items and that's
just total volume divided by the number
of
buckets and so it's a very simple
argument that tells you that
with a good probability your estimate is
at most this term that we claimed here
as i mentioned the space we use is 1
over epsilon log 1 over delta that's
independent of n
and the time for update is log 1 over
delta okay so it's also
independent of n so it's worth looking
at this result a little bit closely
if you want probability of success
reasonable one in 10 100 you're going to
use a few hash functions three five six
this will not know hash functions
that'll be the number of rows
and you want the approximation to be
like 100 you're going to use a bucket
size of about 100 of 100 buckets
so all together you tend to use a few
thousand buckets a few thousand counters
to get a reasonable estimate for these
items that you care about
and it's good when it when the items
you're trying to estimate are very large
with respect to other items
the items you're trying to estimate are
100 of the total volume
then you use about 1000 bytes and you're
able to track this
entire data so it's a very useful data
structure to have
in particular
uh there's a lot of work went into
sort of for the community to reach this
data structure a lot of previous results
before this data structure you space one
over epsilon squared
which is only a polynomial factor in
theory but in practice it turns out to
be quite large so if you want epsilon
one in thousand or one in hundred
then one over epsilon squared turns out
to be hundreds of thousands if not
larger and that will be very that will
be a difficult
memory for the applications that we had
in mind
so a quick observation is can you do
better than this
in space and i'm not going to go through
the proof but there
uh this is for people who are getting
used to their getting into the area you
might want to know that that's a very
nice simple technique for drinking
being able to show lower bounds in this
this world and
almost always they're based on
communication complexity and i'm giving
a very simple
proof here of a simple observation okay
so you start with the problem where
alice has an n-bit
string and bob wants to determine the
ith bit
but in the communication model bob
doesn't get to go and tell alice what
bit
he wants alice gets to go first and she
has to communicate some amount of
information so that bob can figure out
it's a bit
obviously alice does not know the ayat a
bit so one would imagine that alice is
going to have to communicate all the end
bids
for bob to be able to figure out what
was it a bit okay and this can be
formalized
that uh you know i don't want to go into
history of this problem
but we know that you need at least n
bits
or omega in bits for the communication
to work
so assuming that we know this results
now we can show that our problem of
estimating each item
needs at least one epsilon space okay
it's a very simple reduction what you do
is
we're trying to estimate f i
and uh attract the array f so imagine
you have some sort of other another bit
string array i
and every time there is a
a one in the the in the bit string that
alice has think of that as a two in the
corresponding element of the
of the big array and every time there's
a zero in the bit string that alice says
and might think of it as a zero in the
in the f r as well except that you add
an
extra term to the zeroth item in the
array the zeroth item is special
okay so it has this property that once
you do this transformation then you
realize that
if the string that alice had in minus
one over two epsilon in size
then since we added two for every one of
the bits bits in the string
the total volume or total sum of all the
items in the f array would be one over
epsilon
okay and now if you had a method for
estimating
fis very well then in fact if you had a
method for estimating f5
better than the bound that we had for
the countment sketch then
whenever there is a zero in the initial
array it'll turn out to be zero
uh our approximation will only add
epsilon times the total volume but the
total volume is one over epsilon so
that only adds a plus one term at most
to the our uh our fi
so anywhere between zero and one if your
estimate turned out to be between zero
and one you know that original bit was
zero
and similarly if anywhere if they fight
estimate 200
between two and three then you know that
original bit was a one
so in other words you take the bit
string and you think of it as a large
array
now whatever transformations you're done
has a property that if you could
estimate f tilde f
i with better than the accuracy balance
we claimed then you will know the
original bit string okay
therefore you know that the number of
any data structure or the number of bits
stored in the data structure has to be
at least one hour linear in the bit
string size and that gives you the one
over epsilon space
lower bound again this is a almost
straightforward kind of argument uh but
i'm trying to communicate the flavor
that now
many problems in this area will have a
lower bound rise from some sort of a
variation of indexing problem
or generalizations of it some sort of
gap hamming having problems and so on
so i just want to point out that
there's a lot of sketches out there
there are a lot of dimensional reduction
techniques there
and a lot of projecting techniques but
they're not all same many of them tend
to use one over epsilon square space for
this problem
uh that's primarily because they tend to
think about preserving l2 norm
and for this particular problem you
don't need you don't need to preserve
the l2 norm
for the indexing problem so we are able
to do with one over epsilon space
and a lot of algorithms use hashing but
in order to do this
analysis carefully to make sure that
space you use is
is logarithmic you need to make sure
that you know the seeds you need to
argue about the seed length of the hash
functions
and we're going to use pair-based
independent hash functions and argue
that that's reasonable
seed length as well and
the other argument that i hear people
use when they approach a problem of this
type is that well you know
you're getting an approximation for an
item why not use sampling okay
then sampling is a very powerful
technique and it's sort of difficult to
argue that sampling doesn't solve a
problem
but here's a sort of a simple argument
that sampling would be difficult
the basic observation here is that we're
allowed to add and subtract things
and samples are easier to maintain when
you add them when you
delete items then you don't know how to
go back and re-sample
we had to go back and re-sample which we
don't have which we cannot do in the
streaming world
okay so a good way to understand this is
to think of someone who inserts
or adds one to a million items and
you're allowed to keep a thousand
memory data structure so
after having seen a million items you
have some representation of a million
items and it's not going to be exact
and then this person just says that you
chooses to remove
all but four of the items out of the
million items
and eventually you have a you have a
stream of only kinds of four items and
you have a thousand
size bytes as memory and you think that
if you use a sampling procedure then
think about after having seen a million
items if you keep track of a thousand
items
there's a very little probability that
you would keep the four items that
adversary is going to
leave it behind leave behind right your
chance of hitting all the four items is
gonna be very small
but the sketches have a property that
they're totally linear so
if you have a sketch this this continent
sketch for
a million items and if you remove the no
matter which
of the items you removed they eventually
the sketch would be
exactly the sketch for the items are
left behind so you have a sketch of four
for four items using a thousand bytes
and in fact you'll be able to recover
each item explicitly exactly
okay so the linearity is a is a powerful
uh is a powerful technique for us
property for us
so what could do with this data
structure uh
it turns out that you can do a lot of
you can solve a lot of problems once you
have this data structure okay i mean a
good analogy is to think of databases
where once you have indexing you can
solve range queries
and you can solve lots of arbitrary
subset queries and so on quite
efficiently
so so here once you have this indexing
data structure you can ask questions
like well let's assume that
i keep tracking all the updates to this
error if and at some point i want to
figure out
what are the really large items well i
can go through each one of the items one
through n and estimate them
and i need to make sure that all the end
creators get
reasonably good estimates and once i do
that i will find out all the items which
are very large
okay so each index query tells you items
which are large
i'll be able to find out all the items
that are large and it's called heavy
hitters problem
which has been much studied in databases
and data mining you can do a little bit
more we can say that i don't want to
look at all the items one through n and
do the estimation procedure which could
be expensive
so then what you could do is you could
sort of observe that in each bucket
if you want to only figure out the very
large items then this idea of hashing
has a property that it will separate out
the large items individually in each of
the buckets so i'm making a very
powerful statement you have to prove
these things in some big form but if you
take a bunch of items and throw them
randomly into buckets
and if you had a small number of large
items chances are they'll be separated
in the buckets
and in fact they'll be separated in such
a way that they'll be the majority in
each bucket
and then a simple sort of log size
decoding structure will
figure out the identity of the item in
each bucket that's the majority
and it'll take extra login time because
each one of the buckets you're going to
do
extra login work but that that will give
you
a very nice simple result that says that
you will be able to get an think of
initial function f as a signal
you'll get a k term or k
non-zero entry sort of signal version of
the problem such that
it'll be nearly the best thing the best
k term representation for the signal f
where the k terms are individual nonzero
items you'll get a very good
approximation to that
in other words in fact you should
actually be able to get if
if there if the original signal or the
original function f had only k nonzero
items
your representation should actually be
able to find all the k nonzero items
but it's possible that the original
function had k very large items and a
bunch of very very small items
then what you'll find out will be the k
very large items
and the property that your approximation
would have a property that whatever you
left behind will be a very small
function very small volume of the total
signal
so you get a theorem of the type which
is a version of the compressed sensing
result
okay so if i could replace all the ones
l1 norms here
by l2 norms then that would be very
similar to the compressed sensing result
so what we have done is that we've taken
a very simple indexing data structure
and then very simple queries and you got
a result which is
the l1 version of a compressed sensing
result which has got
a lot of applications as we know now i'm
simplifying the story a little bit
you could look at the norms different
norms on the right and left hand side
and there's enormous theory around it
but i'd like to sort of point out this
website that has done some interesting
experiments with this l1 version
and compared it to l2 version which is
something that you hear a lot more
in in in the in the literature
so it turns out that this particular
sketch has been used for solving the
heavy hitters problem as you mentioned
compress sensing
it can be used for estimating inner
products joint sizes
and and it's found over uh last few
years a lot of curious applications
including uh natural language processing
item items
mission learning applications uh there's
a very cute application to password
checking
that got new york times coverage is very
very cute
application and turns out that people
are actually building
now i worked on gigascope as a system in
18t but
turns out that there are other systems
uh uh like steam on sprint sawzall and
milwaukee from google
and the uh that actually have code for
this there are a lot of large number of
code libraries out there
okay uh i was very excited when uh joe
hellisin once sent me an email saying no
i have a question about count me in
sketch implementation
so he has a nice implementation as well
of this sketch
and there are hardware implementations
of this now and
generally it seems to find a lot of
applications
it'll be difficult for me to argue that
this is the best data structure to use
in
every application that where it's being
used uh but on the other hand i think
that uh
it's a simple data structure that a lot
of people understand it and it find it
easy to use them
and and it's not that bad in most
applications
some of these applications actually i
don't know how the sketch gets used
machine learning for example they use it
in very interesting ways with some hash
kernels that i haven't quite figured it
out
but alex muller is one of the experts in
this topic if you want to follow up more
on this
so uh uh i think preston mecca once told
me that i should get really nervous if
people
in the audience start looking at the
watch but he said he should get really
nervous if they start shaking the watch
um
i want to talk about one other primitive
uh
and here again you have a larger if one
through n
and again see updates of increments and
decrements to the items in this array
and again we're going to assume that
there are no negative items okay just to
begin right
i'm not sure there's a restriction for
most of the results i talk about okay
and rather than
solving the indexing problem right now
what i've focused on is
trying to get a sample okay and the
sample
should have the property that when i
look at this array
array there are a bunch of items which
are zero and a bunch of items which are
non-zero
i don't really care how large the
non-zero items are i just want to return
one of the non-zero items with equal
each of the items in the non-zero items
with equal probability so i want to
sample from the
non-zero items say uniformly
you could ask for more general
properties than this there are
this is called l0 sampling in my
language
and there are things like lp sampling
for different p norms
and over the last 10 years there's been
a lot of theory around the sampling but
this is a good enough sample for me to
sort of do the argument i want to do
here
which is you see n items and so there
are increments and decrements
at any given moment there are certain
non-zero items and you will be asked to
get a sample
and you want the sample to have the
property that the non-zero items are
sampled uniformly
obviously you know this data structure
problem has a property that at any given
moment
you could have a large number of items
and then everything gets removed and a
small number of items eventually and
so you should be able to adjust
dynamically to the number of non-zero
items there
and be able to keep track of them and be
able to return one of them
and undo all this in a small amount of
space
there are a bunch of solutions for this
i'm not sure i got the bound right but
there are a bunch of solutions for this
problem
and i'm not going to tell you the
solutions instead i want to tell you
one way to apply this apply this result
and that's for a graph problem
so we're going to use this to define
something called a graph sketch
okay and the way we want to define this
is that uh
um for each node of a graph
you're going to have a vector which is
index for all the other nodes
and we're going to set it to be one or
minus one in a in a sort of an ordered
way right so a i j is one
if j is greater than i and it's minus
one if j is less than i okay there's a
particular reason for setting it to be
one
minus one in this manner okay so for any
given graph
you know we have n vectors one
correspond to each one of the each one
of the
vertices of the graph now if you look at
this closely what
you'll be able to realize that for any
subset of the vertices
if you sum up all these vectors then it
has a securities property that
you're basically catching the capture in
the edge set between the set s and the
uh on the complement of the set yes okay
so
the support of the of the sum would have
this property
sorry
uh and if it's an edge right
if aij isn't is an edge ij's an edge
sorry
i'm sorry
um so a particular edge may
a particular word uh
the reason for focusing on support is a
very only and it's important to look at
the support of this
of this array sum and that has this bro
this property
okay and then what we want to do i'm
going to go a little bit quickly through
this
what we want to do is we're going to now
solve a problem like dynamic graph
connectivity so in other words you have
a graph edges are being added and
deleted
and you want to be able to answer the
connected components of the graph at any
given moment
okay uh this is a well-known classical
problem with the lots of history of
trading of times for update times versus
query times for connectivity and so on
i'm going to just give you one of the
one of the bounds in this space of
results
so you have a dynamic graph problem
where edges are being added and deleted
and at any given moment it might be
asked a query that says is the graph
connected
and what we're going to do is every time
there's an addition of edges or deletion
of an edge we're going to track that
on the on the vectors that we have in
mind each word each word node has
associated vector we're going to think
of it as additional subtractions to that
vector
and in fact what we're going to do is
not maintain that vector we're going to
maintain the
l0 sample or it'll just sketch out that
vector okay
we're going to maintain a data
structural zero sketch from which we'll
be able to get a l0 sample
that is a sample from the non-zero items
with equal probability okay
now then what you want to do is pretty
much run the algorithm that we will
imagine you want to run when you want to
answer connectivity right just
take every node look at an outgoing edge
from there
and then now you have a bunch of
components you can collapse them
and then repeat the process again okay
and
eventually when you would have either
if the graph was connected all the
vertices would have collapsed or there
will be different connected components
and you'll have a representative from
each connected component
so that's the algorithm you want to run
and the cute thing is to observe that
first observation is well given a node
how do you find one of the edges coming
out of it okay
well that's like look at the word the
vector associated with that node
and you want to pull out one of the
a sample l0 sample from that vector
which will correspond to one of the
edges outgoing edges from that
from the node okay that's a simple
observation second observation is that
one
is you have to collapse all these nodes
you collapse the connected components
and the way you do is you look at all
the vertices in the kind of component
and add up the vectors
then when you add up the vectors you'll
have this property that
now you have to that'll be that'll
correspond to collapsing the
nodes of this connected component now
you have to find an edge coming out of
there
and that will be the same thing as
looking at this the data structure that
corresponds to some of these vectors
and picking a l0 sample from that
so in other words we think of an
underlying vector
and we repeatedly have to add those
vectors and be able to pull out
uh l0 sample that is an item from the of
a non-zero support from that vector
and we'll be able to do all of this by
just keeping the l zero sketch of this
vector okay so you you simulate the same
algorithm that we know we can do
except you'll do it with this data
structure samples so there's a very nice
algorithm
that appeared in soda 2012 and
uh very exciting because for a while we
didn't have
nice interesting streaming results on
graphs and you know there's someone
matching and so on
but this was really a nice step and
there's been a bunch of results in graph
such as
sketches since then and i have this
result cited by valerie king
capran and uh i enjoy because it's while
it's a similar it's the same problem
it's not and the techniques are somewhat
similar but they don't
actually phrase it in this manner and uh
um
but it's also a very very very nice
result on dynamic graph connectivity
okay
let me then switch into topics so i so
far what i've done is talk about
accounting sketch on the l0 sketch and
shown applications for each
the content sketches application to
compress sensing the
um l0 sketch has applications to graph
problems and streams
and i just want to now go through a
bunch of little topics
of related results okay so instead of
getting an estimate of
each item if in that in the array you
might want to know
as items get incremented and decremented
you might want to know the l2 normal
square of the l2 norm of the whole
array right it turns out to be a very
useful
function to have and if you hear about
it for the first time it's not
clear that you think it's an interesting
function but it turns out it's a very
useful for many problems we solve in
this area
okay and so it turns out that you can
get an estimate for that
using essential account in sketch okay
in other words you want to now have a
bunch of extra counters
and rather than taking the min over
each of the hash functions you're going
to you're going to do the min again but
for each one of the rows you're going to
slightly different estimator
you're not going to look at the item the
bucket where i fell into but you're
going to look at a couple of buckets and
do the
different squares okay there are a
couple of other ways to estimate this
but this is a simple estimator
for for the l2 norm squared
okay and you'll get one for each one of
the hash functions again you take them
in
okay and there are some details such as
if you
there are some cases where there are
mediums involved but i'm going to talk
about simplest version
to communicate the idea so we have the
same structure as accountant sketch
except that we have a few more buckets
and we always think of the buckets in
pairs and look at the difference
and square them and sum it over the
entire bucket
width and take them in over there over
all the hash functions
and that gives gives you a one plus
epsilon approximation to the
l2 norm okay now
people look at this and we've seen
projections and random projections
johnson windows trust kind of results
can see the connection i mean
uh typically in the random project you
have plus one minus one
for each of the dimensions and you
choose it with some probability and you
project it that way
and we're simulating that by saying that
we're always doing plus ones for all the
projections except that we're
subtracting out a couple of counters
and that has effect of the same effect
as having plus one minus ones
in the transforms now use about one over
epsilon square space the update time is
very fast
and you get a one plus epsilon
approximation delta norm okay
well what can you do with this
uh by the way this is at least faster
update time than any direct
implementation of uh
of results of small space results for
estimating l2
so what can you do with it it turns out
you can do a lot of things with this
data structure
but one good example is solving a
classical least squares approximation
problem
right the least good approximation
problem you're given a large matrix and
you're given a column vector
a large matrix a and a column vector b
and you want to find what's the x such
that a x minus b
is minimized in l2 and all right and
it has a solution with the nd square
time going back to gaussian times
and what you can observe is that if you
don't work with a and b but you work
with
t times a and t times b by t is
transformation matrix given by this
sketch i described before then you have
a much smaller size
problem you don't have an n times d
problem and you have a problem which is
polynomial and size
d and in that space if you solve the
least squares approximation you get a
one plus a problem
that's one approximation to the original
problem okay now you've got to be very
careful you get it one plus epsilon
approximation in the error
or in the vector norm or in okay so that
all the all of the details you have to
work through
but it's very clear that at least if you
look at the error form it should be very
quite easy to show
that if you work with this transform
matrices then you get a one plus
epsilon approximation to the l2 norm and
you can get the minimum
error a one plus epsilon approximation
of the error
and now the running times will be
polynomial d
after this transformation okay the
transformation takes time in d log d
so you have a pretty nice improvement in
these create results from a long time
ago okay
except that this is not exact result it
gives you a one plus epsilon
approximation
now a similar logic
i'm simplifying a lot of a math involved
but a similar logic can be used for
a lot of linear algebraic problems low
rank matrix approximation problems
certain classification problems in
mission learning and so on
and there's been a series of results
in this area and i'm just citing the
most recent result which
looks at the results in an even finer
way of looking at
trying to use some sparseness of the
matrix to get even more improved bounce
okay so in other words you don't want nd
log d you want something that even
depends on the structure of the matrix
and there are such results in this paper
and they're all more or less inspired by
the same observation that once
you can take a sketch to a structure
like this one and map down the original
matrix n times the
matrix to something that is dimension d
a polynomial d
then you can work on that matrix and
it's been very powerful in the linear
algebra area
here is another result so uh
sort of when i was but when i when i was
when i was planning this talk i reached
out to a whole bunch of people in the
community and asked them
what should i talk about and
i was actually surprised by the sense of
pride
in these results in the community i mean
there were people have been a lot of
good results in the last 10 years and
people are really
a very good sense of pride about the
achievements and and
so they had several points that i they
thought i should mention those audiences
and one of them was that while we have
been thinking about this
model of small amount of space polylog
space and
trying to prove results which are
approximate in this model
the techniques that we develop are
presumably useful for a lot of other
problems
which are maybe not even in this model
certainly the dynamic graph
result is on a standard sequential model
and you still get some interesting
results so there was
sense that uh the techniques that we
have in this area
go beyond and have other applications
and there are a bunch of examples and i
don't want to go through all of them but
i do want to mention one nice result
that um
uh that's got a lot of attention
recently which is the problem of
computing the discrete fourier transform
um i was told that a lot of scientists
in the audience and so i'm sure that
this function
means a lot to a lot of you okay signal
processing
relies very heavily on on some version
of fourier transform
and we all know the fast fourier
transform result which is a classical n
log and time algorithm
and
there's been about 20 years of progress
on this problem
um on aspects of special case or
parameterizations of this problem and
a nice result to hook on to this sort of
stream of research
is a paper a site here which says that
if you're looking at a signal for which
you're computing fourier transform and
the signal had
k signals of size n but it had only k
non-zero fourier components
then you can compute it very fast you
can you can you can find this
transformer those coefficients in k log
in time
so imagine the k is less than n then
you're doing it in
significantly better than n log n time
okay and
there's a version of the result you can
apply even when the function doesn't
have a k
non-zero items but maybe k large uh
signals and a few other
other other components have some
non-zero elements as well this is a very
generous result but this result is
already interesting for me okay
it says that if you're dealing with a
fourier transform of signal which has a
square root of n
non-zero components you can actually
find it very fast very nicely
the authors i mentioned here have done
quite a lot of nice work on
implementing these algorithms and and
comparing them and
i would encourage you to look at this if
you're interested in photo transforms in
general
let me mention one other result that i
found interesting uh when you're dealing
with streaming you deal with small
memory data structures but as soon as
you think about the data being on
multiple sites the small memory data
structures become
small communication data structures you
start focusing on communication of
bits and again there's a lot of emphasis
in sciences on learning so i wanted to
give you a result one result in this
area
that i find interesting so here you have
two parties alice and bob and they have
their own data set
and they want to find a linear
classifier on the union of the data set
okay now there's a particular way to
quantify the error of
they're not going to get the the optimal
linear classifier or one that has
minimum error
but they're going to come up with an
approximate linear classifier and it's
going to have some error with respect to
the optimal which is in this case
classified in terms of number of points
that are misclassified by the linear
classifier
okay so once you have such a definition
what they show is that
they have a log one over epsilon round
communication protocol so alice and bob
talked for about log one over slant
rounds and each round has a very small
number of bits like constant number of
bits
and then at the end of it they're going
to have an epsilon error approximation
to the linear classifier
okay in other words it doesn't actually
depend on the number of
items number of data points that each
party has they're still able to get a
good
an epsilon approximation to the global
linear classifier by
by communicating about a constant amount
of bits okay in a few rounds
in fact the rounds are very carefully
done you you start communicating parts
of the convex hell of the agents you
have in order to make sure that
uh the other party has enough
information to proceed so it's actually
an adaptive protocol and uh
but it's a very very nice result and it
was i think independently obtained by
two teams of people and uh they have
generalizes further
it's sort of uh uh it's the beginning of
i think a
nice nice stream of research in this
area
uh i wanna talk a little bit about
privacy okay
there's a beautiful notion of
differential privacy which uh the last
three years has been in the in the
literature and i like it because it it
lets us do
it let's just do math without getting
too caught up in the in the reality
and you know
and so this beautiful notion that says
that i can develop algorithms
and uh guarantee some notion of privacy
okay and
and there was a recent question that
says well i'm assuming you have you have
such a claim that you have a code that
computes an answer to a query
and it's guaranteed to be private so
imagine you want to compute something
like uh
average salary of n people so you can
imagine the data structure keeps each
person's name
and their salary computes the average
and then when it has to give an answer
it gives the answer with the correct
noise added to it
so that the output is differentially
private or has a privacy
but one of the questions that came up
recently was well this is a great notion
but what happens
if you claimed and you had such a
software system and if someone breached
your software and looked at your
memory that you have in your code when
you when you claim to be private okay
very nice question and it sort of it
combines privacy and security
and at least when i heard the question
for the first time i didn't know how to
formalize formulate this as a nice
mathematical problem
okay and what some of the authors did
and i'm sorry i don't have the reference
here on the slide
so they formulated this question a very
beautiful way okay they said well if you
know how differential privacy is
formulated
it says that look at an input and look
at an input which is slightly different
from that input that differs on
input of one of the persons for example
and then
these two inputs should have similar
distribution of output
for all yada yada but that's the notion
of differential privacy
it's a very very nice motion as i
mentioned and the way the authors here
define
a formulated notion of what happens when
there's an internal state breach is that
rather than look at the input think of
inputs like comma the
the state of the memory of the program
that deals with all this computation
this entire combination should be
differentiable private in other words
if there was either a small change in
the input or a small change in the
internal state of the algorithm
then the outputs will still have a
distribution which is similar to each
other
okay so very nice way to formulate this
again you know lends itself to nice math
and what we could show was that using
the techniques of count and sketch in
all zero sketches we can get some of the
pan-private algorithms
the reason i mentioned this is because
if you think of the definition of fan
privacy it doesn't actually have any
restrictions on amount of space used by
a data structure
it just wants to have some guarantee of
privacy no matter
you know assuming that the input and the
state of the algorithm if they're
slightly different the distribution
should be similar
so in fact you could use a polynomial
large exponential large space
in order to get pan privacy but it turns
out that the best algorithms that we
have for plan private algorithms
for plan privacy use polylog space very
small amount of space
okay so the streaming algorithms tend to
have a pen drive privacy
property if used proper carefully
and that's something that ahead of time
not clear that that's the way it should
be
okay and that's i think is an
interesting
connection here finally uh you know i
was i i looked at the audience and i
know that abby big just was going to be
here and a lot of other people shafi was
going to be here
so i had to uh make sure that all roads
lead to cryptography
and then complexity everyone i'm not
there yet okay
so i recently came across a result uh i
haven't had time to uh
read it in detail but i thought the
premise was interesting okay uh
uh at least enough to get started for
some people here okay
so this is a paper this is a manuscript
form and uh it says that
they want to have cryptography against
polynomial adversaries but the algorithm
the
that they want to use is streaming
algorithm okay and the result they have
it's not quite a streaming algorithm uh
it has uh two two tapes
they're both read write tape so it's not
quite polylog space
uh but they make only a few passes for
them okay
and they're able to under some
reasonable assumptions generate certain
one-way functions in pseudo-random
generators
it seemed like a reasonable uh starting
point for something which you know
i i can't really watch for the quality
of the result of the correctness of the
results but i
thought i should mention it something
that i just heard about a week or two
ago
okay and
that gets me to a point where i want to
say that well you know it's an
easy place to look back
i did not mention many many results
okay uh there's some very nice results
on outsourced streaming computation
uh that i wish i could have talked about
uh
uh but you know these one-hour talks are
an opportunity to to uh
to piss off everyone in the audience
but hopefully some hopefully what i
could communicate to you was that there
are
two simple data structures the count
means sketch and l0 sampling
and they're useful tools to have in your
bag
and you'll find that they're useful if
you want to
solve problems with small space but even
otherwise they're often useful
as a quick simple way to derive
algorithms which are sort of approximate
uh but an easy to reason about okay
that's the way i found them to be useful
uh you know taguha who's worked a lot in
this area
uh has given me several examples which i
cannot reproduce without his help of
course no
i don't have the gravitas of sudupto
several examples including physical
location problems linear programming
problems where now he starts out
thinking
from a streaming point of view and that
gives him a handle on sort of
getting improved bounds in complicated
problems like facility location problems
okay i think that's a great great uh
storyline
and what i tried to do was sort of give
you
examples a few topics where there's
research and things that i thought would
be interesting
i like the distributed learning model i
think there's a lot going to be done
instead of it it's a nice connection of
active learning perceptrons and
communication complexity there
i like this pan travis model as i
mentioned uh
ahead of time i would not have known the
right way to formulate the problems
and i still don't have any argument why
the best plan private algorithms had to
be small space algorithms
if you're trying to protect against
somebody breaching your
software and looking at your internal
system
do you have to have a small small amount
of internal memory in order to be
successful it's not a priority clear to
me
but i think it's a nice connection to
explore
and i'm very excited to hear
so many people have an exciting feeling
about this idea of data streams
you know
i'm constantly surprised by how these
results are useful
but two weeks ago i think i got
contacted by a company that said that
they were
implementing count means catch and they
wanted to have me come and visit them
and talk to them about how to extend it
i thought it was surprising you know i
thought there could be a lot of other
data structures that you could use or
being a startup company i thought they
could buy a bunch of machines and do map
reduce and solve these problems
but apparently there's still some room
for doing things with small memory and
very fast and it's very exciting thank
you
could you um throw a holy grail
problem in the streaming world or one or
two
um
so uh i think most people in the
area would say that uh would have said
two years ago that some of the graph
problems were the holy grail problems i
think we made some progress on them
but i still think there's a lot of room
to solve
graph algorithms in the streaming model
and i mean i know it sounds like a
boring thing but actually it's more
exciting than that okay
roughly the argument i would make is
that while in math we you know
mathematicians know graphs for a long
time computer scientists know them we
know graphs for some time
maybe not as long as some of the
mathematicians but the
sort of applied world is discovering
graph as a data structure only now
so only in the last few years that
facebook graph is actually an
interesting
data problem a data set to attack these
problems
and there are lots of problems on these
graphs which are massive graphs which
you know we don't know how to solve them
using even thousands of machines so
any reasonable attempt at approximating
them having fewer communication bits
would be
great i think a lot of problems that are
open
cut problems clustering problems type
one of my favorite
sort of area that's out there that
hasn't been explored is that
there's a model where you have multiple
machines that each of which has a stream
and they all had to sort of talk to a
central site and sort of continually
uh do the computation and so you're
trying you're looking at communication
complexity but you're looking at
continual communication complexity
you're not computing a single function
in one shot
you're computing a function sort of over
time every time it has to be right or
approximate
and you're looking at what is the
cumulative amount of bits that you sent
between multiple sides to the central
side
there's a very nice connection between
that and scraping wolf theorems and
communication complex in communication
theory and
uh so not as it will explode as i think
it should have been explored okay
and finally the paranormal thing that
i'm sure everybody talks about is
there's
large amount of connection between the
small space data structures and
uh sort of what can we do with the model
like mapreduce okay
there are many many variations of map
produce model that come about which
trade out trade-off number of passes
number of rounds
amount of communication and so on and
it'd be nice to sort of tie these models
together in an interesting way
and uh and i think that would be
something that's on most people's minds
okay from a theoretical point of view
and i want to say one more thing from an
applied point of view just
i got interested in these problems
because in early 2000's you know
once if was worked in a t and we these
algorithms were needed in ip traffic
analysis and i felt like i was working
on something that
the world needed i would argue that in
the last 10 years we haven't found
other exciting applications of streaming
systems
okay i think that we've produced very
nice results and i think
they're very useful in a lot of problems
but we haven't had
large scale systems that work with
streaming data and i think that would be
something i love to see the computer
science community sort of find
such applications and we've been looking
talking to scientists we've been talking
to
um internet companies and generally
we're not succeeded in finding a great
common streaming system that will apply
to large
amount of applications